أنت تكتب كثيرًا عن أهمية
الميكروبيوم لدينا وهو شيء
سمعت عنه كثيرًا وأنا مقتنع نوعًا ما
بأنه
مهم للغاية ولكن ليس لدي أي فكرة
عما هو بالضبط أو ما الذي يجب فعله
حيال ذلك ، فما الذي يفسر الميكروبيوم
هو  هذا يشبه صحة أمعائك ،
نعم ، إنها صحة أمعائك
، وكل هذه البكتيريا المختلفة
التي تعيش داخل أمعائك ،
وغالبًا ما يرتبط تنوع تلك البكتيريا
بصحة الأمعاء بشكل أفضل ، لكنني أعتقد أن
السبب في أنني دخلت في هذا على وجه التحديد  كان
لأن الناس كثيرًا ما يقولون إنني
أريد تحسين
المناعة لدي ، وهو أمر جيد
جدًا لفعله ، فهو لا يحل محل
اللقاحات وكل شيء آخر ولكن
فكرة أنك تريد أن تكون مستعدًا قدر
الإمكان  هل تقوم بتحسين
مناعتك وأعتقد أنه بمجرد أن بدأت في
البحث في هذا ، أدركت أن 80 في المائة
تقريبًا من مناعتك الإجمالية تأتي
من أمعائك ، يطلق عليها اسم
galt والأنسجة اللمفاوية المرتبطة بالأمعاء
وأنا فقط  يعتقد أنه كان مثيرًا للاهتمام حقًا ، قال
بعض العلماء
الذين كنت أتحدث معهم حول هذا
الأمر ، إنه محدد جدًا لدرجة أن ما تأكله
في الصباح يمكن أن يكون له
تأثير على مدى خطورة مرض مثل
الطمع الذي قد يؤثر عليك في تلك الليلة
يمكن لمناعتك  غيّر الشمع وتلاشى
بسرعة وبدرجة كبيرة يعتمد على
الميكروبيوم الخاص بك ،
هل هناك أي شيء يمكن للمرء فعله حقًا ،
أعني كيف تحب إصلاح منطقتك الحيوية ،
نعم ، لذا أعني أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، يجب أن
أوضح أنك على حق في بعض
حتى أن الناس قالوا إنه نوع من الدماغ الثاني
بسبب كل التأثير على
الإدراك ومرة أخرى شيء لم أكن أع
فه حتى بدأت في البحث في هذا ال
تاب عن
مية كبيرة من السيروتونين الخاص بك وه
هرمون الشعور بالسعادة الذي تعلم أن
ا نربطه  مع
الحالة المزاجية المرتفعة يتم إنتاجها أيضًا في
أمعائك ونعتقد أنها
نواقل عصبية لوجودها في الدماغ
ولكنها في الواقع تنتج
أمعائك حتى تعرف أنه ليس من المستغرب أي
بو  لكن نظامك الغذائي يؤثر بشكل كبير
على حالتك المزاجية ونعلم أنه
لذلك هناك كل أنواع الطرق
المختلفة لتحسين الميكروبيوم ، أعتقد
أنه كان هناك بضعة أشياء
قفزت إلي ، يمكنك اختبارها ، يمكنك
معرفة
أي نوع منها  الميكروبيوم لديك
وبعض هذه الاختبارات تكون حبيبية
لدرجة أنها يمكن أن تخبرك ما إذا كانت
هناك أطعمة معينة ستكون
أفضل لك أو أسوأ بالنسبة لك ولكن
كقاعدة عامة
كلما كان الميكروبيوم أكثر تنوعًا كان ذلك
أفضل وماذا  يعني أنه من
المحتمل ألا يكون طعامًا فائقًا بالنسبة لك ،
لكن بعض الأطعمة مثل الأطعمة
المخمرة
قد تضيف إلى
التنوع العام للميكروبيوم الخاص
بك.وجدت أنني احتفظت بدفتر يوميات للطعام
لأنني كنت أعمل على هذا النوع من
الأطعمة ، ووجدت أن الأطعمة المخمرة مثل المخللات و
أشياء مثل هذا الكيمتشي كانت
في
الواقع شيئًا جيدًا حقًا بالنسبة لي ، شعرت
بمزيد من النشاط بعد أن أكلت أطعمة مثل
تلك كانت مزاجي مرتفعًا
ثم تعلمت أنه ربما كان
تأثيرًا  بالنسبة لمناعي أيضًا ، لا
أريد تبسيطها بشكل مفرط لأن
هناك طرقًا
لاختبار صحة الميكروبيوم الخاص بك
والأشياء الخاصة به لأشخاص محددين ، لكنني
أعتقد أنه من الآمن أن نقول إننا لم
نعطها الكثير من الاهتمام لك  نعلم و
80 في المائة من مناعتنا تأتي تقريبًا
من ذلك ، لذا يجب علينا ذلك